in a historic settlement gun  manufacturer remington has settled with  the families of the victims of the sandy  hook massacre for 73 million dollars  this settlement is really interesting  for a number of different reasons first  it's double what remington offered to  pay in july it's also the first time  since the federal protection of lawful  commerce and arms act passed in 2005  which made it almost impossible to sue a  gun manufacturer basically that law made  guns exempt from normal product  liability rules and made it impossible  to sue a gun manufacturer when their  guns were used in the perpetration of a  crime that was until the connecticut  supreme court ruled that in 2019 that  the law didn't shield gun manufacturers  from their advertising of guns and  that's what the sandy hook case really  focused on but keep in mind that  remington filed for chapter 11  bankruptcy in july of 2020. so we'll see  how this plays out